[Music]
hi welcome to the pretty intense podcast
I'm Danica Patrick thank you so much for
listening today on the show is Erin
Alexander he has an amazing method
called the alignment method he has a
book called the alignment method he has
a podcast called the alignment podcast
he is also a movement coach and a manual
therapist all you have to do is check
out his Instagram which is align podcast
as his Instagram and check out just like
how he moves and the things that he does
with his body to create stacking and
alignment and I say that but that's not
actually what we talked a ton about in
this episode this episode had a lot to
do with the emotions and your mind and
your reality and just sort of like where
your body stores tension and then how
that sort of like shows up in your life
as like you know if you are tense about
a relationship you tense your body up
and
how there's no separation between the
physical body and the mental emotional
body and you know even one of my
favorite therapies which I would have
imagined to be a mental emotional
therapy he said is a somatic Body
Therapy which is EMDR because it's a
rapid eye movement so it's like using
the body to access information and
um uh it's just you know the
conversation was very very deep and very
very flowy and very emotional and really
going into all the aspects that create
our reality and and and the way that we
show up and the challenges that we have
and essentially how we just get out of
alignment with ourselves so I hope you
really like this episode I hope you
learn a lot please hit subscribe and if
you want notifications for the episodes
the bell and please let me know what you
think about this episode in the comments
and maybe some modalities that you use
to help yourself both physically and
mental emotional how are you today thank
you I am well and I just got back from
the gym it's incredibly sunny it's like
I think 75 degrees or something in
Austin so I've been spending a lot of
time outside which is good I was
wondering where you lived I wasn't sure
if it was like California or no I joined
I joined the mass migration to Austin
Texas I'm a part of that in like 2020 or
2021 yeah a year and a half ago oh why
um I was just I've been in La for five
years and was feeling like ready for
some type of change in general and then
with all like the lockdown stuff and
politics I was kind of like good on
hearing people's opinions about things
um and also taxes and then also
Community would be my my bullet point
list of why Austin was a reasonable
Place how about that how about that list
do you feel like you check have you
checked it off yeah yeah yeah awesome
like what's the reality of
what Austin
lacks I would say is geographically it's
not that interesting you know it's like
a lot of like Rivers you know it's very
it's very it's it's the most like normal
place that I've lived in my life other
than I grew up in Pennsylvania but I
moved I moved to Hawaii when I was 18
and then Boulder Colorado and then Bend
Oregon and then Santa Monica
you know so all the places I lived were
very like idyllic places that you know
from around the world be like wow that'd
be amazing to go on vacation there
Austin's the first place that I've lived
it feels like it's like Minnesota you
know it's like it's very like normal
come on now there is nothing Minnesota
about
Austin Texas just geographically it's
not like the postcard kind of reality
that like Hawaii or Colorado is for
example like I'm from the middle of
nowhere in Illinois so like Minnesota
feels real similar and I'd be like no no
Austin's way way way cooler and better
than uh it's a way cooler and better no
no it's not Minnesota it's just it's the
closest thing to that whereas La is like
very you know it's a bunch of dreamers
and all the things Austin is that now
because a lot of that demographic came
here
um but it's it's more it's just more
normal which I think is good like I'm
saying normal in a good way like there's
something nice about people people that
are I think a little bit more like down
to earth in a way
um a little bit more dependable
um people that are like cool like we're
here let's just be here whereas La has
more I think of a temperament of
um yearning for something else like
we're all here for something else like
what are you here I'm like I'm here to
fulfill this dream be an actor yeah
whatever it is and like whatever I met
now it's not this like I'm here to be
somewhere else
there's certain places in the rest of
America or United States that's a bit
more like oh like you know what do you
like what are you doing here I'm like
I'm an electrician and I'm I have a
family and I'm here this is it it's like
oh cool like that's great like there's
something kind of gratifying like you
fit in did you fit into that I'm not
where I want to be when you lived in
California is that sort of part of the
part of the
um process of of being in that area or
do you feel like that was never you
I fall into that category that's yeah
that's been something I've been
um I think working on reconciling for a
while well let's talk about that
oh yeah yeah we can
um and that is something that I am
I think I'm in process of finding more
consilience with where I'm at and where
I want to be and just accepting my self
in the moment and like now and like this
is good like I love me now like I love
my house I love my car I love what I'm
doing I love this conversation like I
love being here
compared to the possibility of most
things uh being like means to an end you
know does this lead me to there
and that's how you used to feel more of
the time
uh yeah I would say yeah I mean there's
there's a certain
magnetism of a place like Los Angeles
and I think I fell into somewhat fell
into like some of the stereotypical
category of I went there to like grow my
business grow my podcast you know get a
book deal and like you know make
something of myself
um and it was and I was I was
successful to to at least
semi-successful at doing that so I'm
very grateful to La I'm not like poo
pooing on La in any capacity but a part
of that as well is being or part of the
life thing is is finding gratitude and
contentment and fulfillment with what
you have in front of you because you
have so much probably
um and then from there building upon
that compared to building from a place
of lack and anticipating feeling
fulfilled once I arrive some other place
that's just you know a bunch of a bunch
of Huey what uh what were some of those
sort of Shadow aspects that you feel
like you confronted that helped you feel
more
at peace or content
um well I'm in therapy right now for the
first time that I'm really like actively
excited about therapy I like to look
forward to it everyone's doing therapy
it's so cool forever
therapy for yourself like I used to like
100 years ago and I had all many
lifetimes ago like therapy was for a
relationship but like that's just that's
just a Band-Aid in my opinion like
therapy is of the utmost importance and
it should always be for yourself
yeah well so for me a relationship is
what catalyzed the necessity of said
therapy and the the reflection of how
much
um
how disconnected from all of myself that
I've been largely like childhood bits
yeah and there's been a a lot of
um
self-abanding I guess I could say and a
lot of like young boy even like baby
um
statues of myself within myself where
it's kind of like Frozen like vision of
your inner child is like very statuesque
like little boy yeah well the statues in
the sense that it's it's like aspects of
myself Frozen in time because at some
point in time I didn't have the
resources or the capacity to address it
and I think that's the definition of
trauma and Trauma is one of those words
that's words that gets tossed around a
lot a particularly if you live in a
place like Southern California uh or or
Austin for that matter
and sometimes it can be just Southern
California yeah and so I can I I
historically have had somewhat of an
allergy of sorts to different buzzwords
like that doing the doing the work
trauma you know re-parenting yeah inner
child
and then you you get involved and you're
like oh my God this is this is this is
actually a thing I didn't know holy [__]
why am I crying right now
oh my God
yeah and having having very clear
visuals like psychedelic level visuals
not psychedelic like sacred geometry
spiraling out you know lizards crawling
up my my chest or anything but but
psychedelic in the sense of just very
Vivid visuals of um almost more clear
than psychedelics I would say of myself
uh as a baby
and uh feeling feeling like lonely
feeling alone uh and feeling
afraid to love and afraid to open myself
up to love because I don't trust love
because I'm afraid that I will be hurt
again
yeah again and so that a part of the
like the visuals that I've I've learned
the visual experience that I've had
that's that's educated me and now
talking to my parents more like one of
the visuals I've had is my parents in
kind of like a statuesque type form uh
almost like two chess pieces like a king
and queen and looking away from me but
like wanting to look back but not not
knowing how or not no yeah they didn't
have the tools they didn't have the
tools and so they so they were and are
still in a lot of ways
um
maybe lack resources or perhaps afraid
in some way or just calloused over it in
some aspects of like deep authenticity
with their own access to intimacy and
trusting of Love worse and then so
within that
your parents love you to the max degree
that they can yep and their their hurt
people and they're lovely people and
they're beautiful people and they're
they're all of the things but a part of
of that most people also are a little
hurt
and that's not everyone some people
might have completely cleared their
baggage of the past and their ancestry
and all of that no I don't know they
could it could it could exist I'm just
not barring that out as an impossibility
okay maybe there's some like bodhisattva
figures out there that's like no we
really really I've really unpacked the
[__] like there is no more [__] to
unpack there is nothing left underneath
tree yeah my my feeling is if a person
was in that orientation I don't know
that they would hold a body anymore
which gets a little out there oh my God
that's exactly the truth no I totally
agree I yes I mean through like
psychedelics and seeing certain things
like understanding that this is not real
and we agree to this and part of me also
has said like I wonder if certain things
are just inherent with this experience
of being a human and if you didn't buy
into these sort of constructs and have
these polarity Dynamics I wonder if
you'd even be here because when you know
that it's not real or you don't buy into
the the game like I really truly wonder
if you could hold form
yeah you might not need to I mean that's
the belief system
Western culture generally has a bit of
dis-ease around the concept of death
you know it's like really sad and it's
like devastating and it's a shame and
it's a travesty and it's a question mark
and it's a lot of that I don't think
there's a there's not a lot of of
definition around death as being
something that's really beautiful or
something that's that's really like
um
at least as beautiful as life you know
or as birth and then perhaps even like
there's a I think maybe Ram Dodge Ram
watch or something like this has a bit
of around you know if you graduated
early from the fourth grade and you like
got sent to the seventh grade it would
be like wow this is amazing like this is
not a bad thing it's not like it's like
oh my God I'm not in the fourth grade
anymore and so if you go to India which
I haven't been but I've heard stories of
this uh death is one public uh two
you're exposed to it because you
probably live with your parents
um and so just throughout one's life
you're going to be exposed to death and
then the way that they do burials like
you can see the body and put them in the
the river the Genghis River or whatever
it's called and it's just very like it's
like a big part of life and life becomes
more this preparation for death it's a
much more entwined relationship to death
and also
it could be considered like a graduation
of sorts so if someone dies quote
unquote young that could also be
something like cool they like they they
didn't need this body anymore you know
and I don't I don't personally align or
misalign with that I just am aware that
it feels like there's a lot of kind of
like shadowy kind of curiosity empty
space around the concept of death in our
culture and we just don't want to talk
about it I was going to ask what you
thought the percentage
of well-being is attributed to if you
were to divide up a hundred percent of
physical
versus emotional mental like how much of
what how would you divide that up
because that's kind of how I think we'll
divide up the time today because you do
deal a lot with the physical body but I
wonder what you think the value of that
is as a percentage I don't know that
it's tough to differentiate a percentage
because I think that they are congruent
then we have to establish what
well-being is so if you I think if you
if you so you could make the body be fit
like physically fit right but sometimes
for example a person might be really
flexible but they might carry a massive
amount of tension somewhere in the body
right or they might be really strong or
like any of the things they might seem
like in really great shape but
oftentimes what that is I would fall
into this category they're they're
really brilliant at compensating and
they've they've oftentimes what looks
like the cover of muscle and fitness or
you know you might see like the rock or
somebody like that and you see that like
wow he's jacked and awesome and better
than me and like nothing could be wrong
in his life like look at that and so I
think that it's it's easy to get and I
don't know the rock so you know he might
be in this bodhisattva category but
nothing it's very easy to get confused
by just physical largeness or
chiseledness or something of the source
you man you just want bigger muscles all
the time it's always more yeah for a
girl bigger butt or no
ways to hip ratio give you a smaller ass
I want a smaller ass oh that's good good
for you I love that [__] bucking
bucking the Norms of the day yeah but so
yeah so someone
I would say I fall into category of like
a a really good compensator and so an
example of compensation in the physical
body would be a person that maybe like
they pull their shoulders back they puff
their chest out and then from the time
if they did like a like a high school
yearbook photo be like wow they look
pretty good like they've pulled it all
back big chest big strong shoulders but
physically posturally what that that
will do if you haven't integrated that
through the whole body is you'll just
end up tipping the pelvis forward too
much and going to hyper lordosis and you
know you might have your feet end up
going a little externally and into
pronation and you just don't see it in
the yearbook photo so you don't see the
part that that people are looking right
at and so a lot of us are focusing on
what do people see and what do I see in
a mirror and that's fine
and it will uh it will burble up and it
will manifest itself as something
you know and and so I think a are you
saying like a a a true physical
challenge meaning some kind of back
issues or your some joint issue are you
talking about dis-ease in the body
through more things like cancer or uh
autoimmune or something like that or
both I don't I don't know about cancer
and autoimmune I just had Gabor mate on
my my podcast just like a week ago or
that episode just came out
um and he he's he goes really deep into
the relationship of like anger towards
one's self or anger in general
swallowing one's anger as opposed to
being able to like process and release
and that potentially manifesting itself
into something where the body begins to
you know like attack itself or like if
there's maybe some kernel of self-hatred
uh things of the sort you know I don't
know enough about that to have any
meaningful opinion uh the whole field is
called
psychoneuroendocrinology people are
interested in going deeper into any of
that stuff Peter Levine is a great
resource awaken the tiger within Bessel
Vander calc uh is really good as well
the body keeps the score
yeah all those are really great
resources I have like more of a footing
and is I think the way that expresses
itself in an orthopedic way and also
just in body language
now so if a person really feels calm
they feel safe they feel supported they
feel loved they feel fulfilled they feel
like ah like this moment like I like
this you'll notice probably they're not
gonna front and puff the their chest out
in like a prideful way they'll just
allow their shoulders to relax
you'll notice the tone of their voice
will probably start to be a little bit
more a little lower a little slower a
little like you'll notice their
breathing patterns will be more geared
towards a long relaxing exhalation it's
really easy for them to
you know so and there you'll notice
their Vision might be less myopically
focused you know less like a shark get
stuff done Predator prey type
relationship in your eyes let me look
away yeah right exactly and your your
eyes are continuous with your central
nervous system and their neurological
tissue it's like it is your brain
and so all of these our senses are all
interrelated with our our thoughts
feelings and physiological expression
and so we have bought the idea that you
know you're Danica Patrick I'm Aaron
Alexander I'm uh you know this is my
profession this is my personality this
is a car I drive this is this is who I
am you're also an animal you're also you
know like like this this looks like
mammalian reptilian old million year old
creature
conspiracy I'm not a
yeah whatever you're also maybe Spirit
right you're also you're also maybe a
mother maybe a father maybe you know
maybe a son maybe you're also hurt
you're also you're so many things yeah
yeah but but we for ease and convenience
we kind of put ourselves into a package
for easier Pro easier processing you
know but you can just when you start to
look at the body language of a person I
think you see a lot of honesty come out
and it's less story and more just ah
here you are like your jaw is
chronically tense your muscles around
your neck are clamped down all the time
your diaphragm is chronically contracted
you're not able to take a full
exhalation like you're blocked from
exhaling
exhalation is tied into the
parasympathetic nervous system
so perhaps you don't feel safe to Exhale
where did you learn that maybe it was
something you learned before you even
had words
or not maybe it's something you learn
when you're 15 maybe so so it becomes
you know the the emotional aspect of the
self it just is congruent with the
physical expression
so can you separate those in a sense
like obviously you're probably not
taught like oh your exhale is your
parasympathetic and this is how you I
mean there's more thought more more
narrative around around breath work
these days but are you saying that you
can also you can come at it from the
other perspective meaning I feel like
it's probably an Adaptive sort of thing
when you you're tense because for some
reason you needed to be yeah program
that way something happened in childhood
where your environment
conditioned you to adapt that way so can
you then now come at it from the other
perspective of going like okay this is
how you get out of being in sympathetic
mode to drop into parasympathetic with
these with these um modalities that
shift your pattern yeah yeah it's not
probably adaptive it is adaptive yeah
it's great like it's so cool like the
body is so smart and the body is is so
honest yeah and it's so beautiful yeah
and we don't really listen to it
collectively it's like huh interesting
oh yeah it's when you have something pop
up and all of a sudden you you know your
whole body is covered in Goosebumps and
you're like and so those for me now I'm
like oh that's a yes like that's a
that's a that's like a that's like an
energetic Quantum field yes through the
body and then other times you know
you're like you tense up in your solar
plexus or maybe in your heart but you
but you're not paying attention right
you're just like oh that's nothing but
really it's information about your
environment and what you need to be
paying attention to yeah or maybe you
don't want to pay attention because you
prefer the narrative that you have
within your mind of course right which
is also fine and that's called denial
which is also fine it's not there's no
I would say I'm making this up right now
it's the first time I'm like I'm going
into this stuff which I can get in
trouble in podcasts and recorded
conversations where we'll go into
territory like I've never been here but
here we are
um but I would I would say that would be
denial yes if you are and I could you
know be wrong about this so please like
play Devil's Advocate but if your mind
the story that you have goes against
your visceral yes no
um
personally if I were betting I would
lean on the visceral mm-hmm
answer or solution compared to the
mental answer solution wow and so if
you're if your mental has so much
bandwidth because you're all like living
above your shoulders you're all in your
head you don't really have a strong
relationship to your your interceptive
self which is a 50 Cent word for like
feeling your internal experience which
is also tied to eating disorders which
is interesting a person that has lower
interceptive IQ would also have a higher
likelihood of having some type of
disordered eating which is kind of
interesting also like anxiety and things
of the sort because there's a disconnect
from my relationship to myself yeah
there's a disconnect with that I it's I
I don't want to feel it or maybe I never
learned how to feel it or maybe I never
learned it was safe to feel it or maybe
I'll never even learned it was a thing
to feel because I've been all on
books podcasts
screens you know and what I should do as
opposed to who I am which I know this is
getting like very like maybe
metaphysical and out there but something
it's great no the audience loves this
stuff they love okay all my physical
scientific
um yeah no I believe that's 100 the case
because whatever happened in your
childhood programming taught you that
you're to survive because essentially
the point is surviving right so uh when
we're a child we can't feed ourselves we
can't drive ourselves to school we can't
you know there's so many things that we
can't go to the grocery store yet so to
survive we do actually need to adapt and
so you know disconnecting from those
feelings within ourselves that are
screaming something which are telling
and giving us information about our
parents our environment or our caretaker
we have to turn it off and that's a
means of survival yeah yeah and then and
that's bad all the time would be hard so
you disconnect yeah and so coming into
that I think that there's for for me at
least
um I I personally have experience and
hopefully it resonates with somebody but
some level of
um
denial and maybe even like shame around
not being like fully integrated as a man
really and how how did that show up
uh just not not really having
availability to vulnerably look at
myself in something that's like not a
like a full so your own shame not
someone else making you feel shameful no
no me yeah me me feeling subconsciously
ashamed because oh I'm still kind of
like locked in Old hurt boy modes in
certain in certain ways but how did you
become aware that's beautiful therapy
yeah yes I think I think is somatically
based therapy particularly you know so
there's there's different versions of
that there's somatic experiencing would
be something a Comey method would be
something semantic semantic experiencing
comes from Peter Levine hakomi comes
from I don't know the founder of that
off the top of my head right now
um also EMDR is an example of that at
all yeah oh is that a somatic really
somatic just means of the body so so if
you're doing a talk therapy or it's just
two Talking Heads talking about the
things in their heads yeah I personally
don't get a ton of value from that
because it feels more like a person
giving you fish compared to leading you
to water and teaching you how to fish
and I believe that when you when you are
working from a place with a a skilled
practitioner who is able to observe
where are you manifesting some type of
contraction or sensitivity or like
quote-unquote trigger of sorts where
you're like whoa like notice your eyes
change a little bit notice you're kind
of like self-soothing notice your voice
went up a little bit when you said that
like let's stay with that there's
something there
and they're like okay maybe close your
eyes let's like okay now bring your
awareness out of your head out of your
story and you know let's just bring your
awareness into your chest and just
breathe there you don't need to do
anything okay remember maybe bring your
wrist into your abdomen your belly you
know you don't understand we're not
doing anything you know and just feeling
into that space and just notice if
anything comes up for you and notice
maybe if there's any relationship to
um you know you could maybe you you feel
anxious maybe you feel depressed maybe
you have some type of like addictive
behavior there's a way to track the
origins of that in the body
and if we can be open and vulnerable
enough to kind of open up our chest
and or open up our abdomen or open up
our pelvic floor
and say like okay like you know what do
you have anything to say anxiety do you
have anything to say sleeplessness do
you have anything to say obesity or
irritable bowel syndrome or anger old
repressed rage you have anything to
share and then when if you have the
availability and the vulnerability
um and and like the safety and the and
typically the guidance
to do that it's like oh you have a lot
to say yeah I had no idea because I
haven't really had the capacity or know
how to listen and when you if you and
then once that Journey Begins then you
realize it's validated and you're like
okay all the stuff that I thought was
just a bunch of like new age like Hui
actually is rooted in something pretty
interesting and something pretty
impactful that's the reason so many
people are so popped up on it it's just
usually language language and deep
visceral somatic experience it's it's
not the easiest to bridge that sometimes
there's certain people that can bridge
that well
and they're I think really valuable in
culture
um but for the most part it's kind of a
lot of people it's just it's hard to
explain and it's not scientific and it's
not measurable and it wasn't 25
milliliters of repressed rage you know
and it's not a double-blind study it's
like human qualitative experience
and Western culture isn't really about
that as much as we are like quantitative
experience well nobody really likes to
see the darkness nobody really nobody
really wants to to see where their
shortcomings are and where they need to
heal because essentially one of the most
frustrating Parts is that your trauma is
not your fault but your healing is your
responsibility one of the most important
things that there my therapist told me a
couple of years ago was that no one
holds the keys for you like I was like
oh my God I was like I have to do this
all myself that's like overwhelming you
know just to think that like this is all
my fault and my responsibility to heal
and move forward from but essentially
that really is the work is like how do
you shift how do you become someone that
doesn't attract certain patterns or
people that are not good for you and how
do you shift your perspective
so that you can see things in a new way
and how do you change so that the things
that you see change you know and
um yeah but when you were telling me
when you're telling stories at the very
beginning about the stone figures and
things I immediately thought that was
maybe from EMDR is that where you saw it
and through EMDR I've never I've never
done EMDR you you have you seemed like
you like oh my goodness yeah it's so so
good I literally just did it yesterday
oh cool um it's uh it's a yeah if you've
never tried it it is like it is like
time travel it is like psyched it is
like an Ayahuasca trip meets you know
therapy because it's very poignant you
know it's really to the point about
something and then within the modality
which I was trying to always make sure
people know EMDR is not
in any way crazy weird or challenging or
dangerous it's literally just like my
therapist uses a buzzer in each hand so
it just vibrates back and forth from
side to side it's not something you take
it's not something you have to it's just
it's very simple
um but it's like time travel I actually
I had have you heard of Dr Ayman yeah
I've had one podcast a couple couple
times I've worked with them a little I
interviewed him as well after I went and
had a brain scan and I was having a
conversation with him and my doctor that
I was working that I have been working
with for a long time and some of the
things that he said were the most
beneficial to do were one Hyperbaric but
two EMDR and he was like just and I had
done EMDR a few times and I thought it
was insanely powerful and the stories
that I was able to see were like
unbelievable I could see it not only
from an observer perspective of myself
but the other person or the other
Dynamic I was looking at I could see
even like their own childhood
programming of what made them like that
and how their parents treated them
um I could see
um higher soul orchestration from an
energy or entity
above above this experience that was
like maneuvering and making events
happen for the benefit of the experience
like it was it's trippy
um but he just was like
it was a great thing to recommend make a
list of your top 10 traumas and then
just go into EMDR and deal with them go
fix them and I don't remember any memory
that uh in the original form after EMDR
I only remember how I saw it in EMDR
yeah memory is interesting the the idea
of like like what is memory in the first
place
kind of gets in like what is time you
know but like memory is a recapitulation
of It's A Memory of a memory of a memory
of a memory
so you can you can develop a story about
a thing and you see this happen in court
cases regularly which is why there's a
lot of people that are in jail for their
whole life unjustly because someone had
a memory uh I was definitely that person
is like nope your memory was not even
close that is not what happened bro
those aren't memory paternity tests
aren't memory but other than that yeah
but so but memory is interesting because
it's it's because it's it's painted by
our filter of perception well so it goes
It goes through filters Jordan Peterson
talks about this and someone else maybe
but just that memory is
happens past present and future
essentially because as soon as like as
as soon as you have some event change
now the whole past changes and your
future changes so like with information
and the way you remember like like the
whole thing is intertwined into being an
adjustment of reality in all ways it's
um yeah it's uh it's it is trippy I mean
memory is definitely what about
um another sort of topic I've been
um riffing on with people is the idea of
objective reality
and how you just said you know your
perception your lens
colors the entire event and so two
people don't see the same event the
exact same way I'm betting that two
people don't even see necessarily like
if I look outside at nature like they're
not you and I wouldn't even see it
exactly the same way things stand out
colors may be different like I don't
think that that I I wonder basically the
the philosophizing is do you believe in
objective reality it's painted by your
trauma I would say largely yeah yeah so
I think that the trauma is the part I
think if a person if there was two
people that were completely unpacked
let's say that's a possibility my sense
is probably their their uh objective
experience of the world around them
would be pretty similar in a lot of ways
it would be clear
once you get a Twist in the system and
suddenly maybe I was raised with a dad
that hit me my dad didn't hit me like we
got spanked a few times or whatever but
that wasn't the thing
um but maybe you did and then every time
someone raises their hand up to give you
a high five because you have an
unprocessed
bracing around that your experience with
that high five dramatically different
than someone that doesn't have that
quote trauma so that I think is where it
really it it brews some deep like
reactivity that reactivity really
augments a person's perception and then
if a person feels I think the resting
state of the human being is uh ease
if we feel safe to be at ease if you
learn that it is safe to be at ease but
if you haven't if you've learned that
you need to be on edge you need to be on
the ready your dad that hits you comes
home you can hear the the subtlest
little the the manner in which he opens
the door
you become queued up to oh man I think
he's been drinking he stumbled a little
bit as he came in oh he kind of slammed
the door
oh God all my sphincters clench up like
okay here we go like this is this is
what's happening
you know and so that changes at a deep
deep visceral level to come into a place
of
um you know like reactivity but if a
person can actually process all of that
and come to a place where like
you know I've come into acceptance with
all the things I've actually seen and
heard you know and just really deeply
felt all of all of the emotions and I
can actually really come to this present
timeline I'm actually here my sense is
that's probably pretty
um like a pretty concilling experience
where it's just uh yeah it's probably a
lot of ease I would I would I would
imagine does that make sense I know that
it's a little laundry I interviewed a
girl her name she goes by The Alchemist
Instagram and on on YouTube Sarah
alcaldy is her name and we had a
conversation about objective reality and
she said that the more you see reality
through the Observer perspective of your
higher self the closer essentially the
closer to Enlightenment you are which
she's like is not some massive thing
it's just you just understanding that
you are everything
um but she's like the more you can see
it from that perspective that is the
because she said so if there's a camera
because my example was you know four
people watch a car accident you know
they all have four different stories no
matter how much they want to tell the
truth about exactly what happened and
she said well and I asked about the
Observer or about objective and she said
well if there's a camera
watching the event that is the objective
reality so the more you can get above
the trauma the more you can get above
those above yourself and your own
narratives and perspective and see and
see it from your higher self the more
the the then you're then you're seeing
objective reality yeah yeah I like the
idea that like Enlightenment isn't that
big of a deal I think I think
Enlightenment ultimately I don't know
that I've ever I might have had like
fleeting moments where it's like oh it's
pretty enlightened for a minute or
something of the sort but it's just yeah
I think it's a it's a sensation of
Unicity it's a sensation of connection
um that like Oneness all the things that
you know hippies talk about I think
that's pretty and then they they do a
pretty deplorable job at actually
explicating it and turning into
something that's digestible for someone
that hasn't had that that experience uh
but I think the idea where I have
weariness and skepticism is around
someone that feels like they're in some
level of like Perma Enlightenment mode
and that's where I'm kind of like I just
might not be enlightened enough to to
get that in an embodied way and so I'm
like okay like I feel like you're
probably in denial
um of something but I don't I don't know
that Enlightenment operates in that
fashion where it's just a permanent
thing I think that like there's a
reference ROM Das a lot because I like
them
but he he has he has a bit about
um all of his Neurosis he's he still has
all of them freaking ramdas you know
like he's like there's not many people I
think that are Beyond I mean he doesn't
consider himself enlightened I guess as
well he says I'm enlightened in some
ways but
um you know I consider him pretty high
up in the echelons of of Consciousness I
guess you could say and he says he has
all of the the same Neurosis since he's
been a kid it's just before they were
like these overwhelming monsters that
owned him whereas now they're like these
little kids and you can see them pop up
and like oh there's the sexual thing or
there's the greed or there's the fear of
being left out
yeah and so and so the Observer because
you're seeing yourself
this is why like meditation it
structurally changes the gray matter in
the brain you know like changes the
shape of the hippocampus changes the
shape of the of the amygdala uh it
literally it it it adds size to the
hippocampus by sitting there and just
being The Observer uh and then that's
that's not weird that's just like the
brain change if you if you drink a bunch
of alcohol your brain changes if you
exercise your brain changes if you take
a walk like everything changes the brain
so by you by you sitting in observation
it structurally changes the shape of
your of your neurological system which
is
pretty cool but so so the reason I'm
saying that is it's all a choice of
where we place our attention so if you
place your attention if you allow your
attention to be Dust In The Wind in the
modern world
I don't think it's wise because when you
look at one your attention is being vied
for by you know advertisers largely so
they're trying to sell you stuff
nothing wrong with that
but oftentimes the way to sell a person
on stuff this goes back to uh it was
actually the the nephew of Sigmund Freud
uh I'm spacing his name right now but he
was considered Edward Bernays he was
considered the the father of modern
advertising and what shifted that
approach to advertising I think it was
like in the early 20s around when like
cigarettes become were coming popular
was instead of advertising the actual
objective qualities of the product this
car is really good it's got this size
engine it's got these tires made in
America it's good you know good quality
there was a shift into more tapping into
one's identity based off of owning this
product so if you own this product you
will be the coolest guy at school and
you'll have muscles and all the girls
will love you and it's like it's it's
selling that that story of yeah you're
selling The Narrative of of who I could
be yeah man if I owned if I was a if I
owned a Macbook I would be a Macbook
kind of guy but it's it's baked into the
cake
to be bombarded by advertisements pretty
much all day since you're a baby like
TV's running you're driving the car you
see Billboards like it's everywhere it's
not bad it's just the way it is and most
of them are saying you will be enough
when you buy my [__] it starts to ship
things around a little bit you know and
so and so starting to unpack that uh I
think you know it's a whole process the
the
angle that I come in to any of these
conversations it really is physicality
so okay your back hurts you lack
shoulder range of motion you have
shoulder pain shoulder impended syndrome
you know your hips feel stiff your
ankles don't move right uh you don't
you're limited and you're running uh you
feel just achy aches and pains and you
just like like crepitus in your body
it's like that to me is my starting
point because I feel like that's a great
door into all the conversations it gets
into nutrition it gets into physical
movement
that just starts the conversation
yeah I think it's a really important
starting point because I I feel like a
person
unless you're already you've already
like drank the Kool-Aid of conversations
like this I think it's hard for a person
to be like that's really interesting but
I have to I'm behind on my rent
um I'm freaking out about my
ex-girlfriend or girlfriend I have two
kids they need to be fed uh my back is
in terrible pain uh I can barely get out
of bed in the morning like all this
spiritual
psychosomatic neuroendo whatever is like
I this is this is where I'm at I need to
sort this out people deal with whatever
their biggest problem is at the moment
and so you know um the world is telling
you there's a million problems with you
know propaganda with advertisements
you're not enough you're not cool enough
if you don't have this if you don't have
enough more more money if you don't do
this and that and then you know so
what's their biggest problem my freaking
back is just annoying me every day like
you know that's just where they start
like you start with the biggest problem
and so yeah you you sort of look at the
body as essentially like the gateway
drug to more what I would call a
holistic life I think people I think
people maybe three of people's top
things would be Health relationships and
money those are three pain points where
it's like I think spirituality you know
and all that stuff I I don't think
that's high in the ranking of of Western
culture at least
and the reality like there's an
interesting book I'm actually having the
author of this book uh on the podcast
coming up called the soul of money an
interesting book and it it's one of the
many books that kind of gets into money
just being this this energetic flow I
know and the way that we interact with
money is is it's just a relationship
thing you know so so a person could be
backed up on their relationship with
money and be chronically saving and
hoarding and well I don't want to let it
go uh and then it's like oh interesting
like whoa where does that come from do
you feel like there's the shoe is gonna
drop at any time
and you're not gonna have enough and
you're like you're clenching waiting for
that to happen where did that come from
oh it might have come because you
learned that in a validated way as a as
a young kid or whenever like oh yeah the
shoe does drop it will all be taken away
you need to prep and then you become a
prepper and so there's the possibility
to come back and say holy [__] the way
that I relate to my bank account is
pretty darn spiritual in a way and
pretty darn like metaphysical and pretty
darn therapeutic you know and you could
do the same thing with relationships oh
my God I'm like clenching down in this
relationship or maybe I'm resisting I'm
staying distant I don't want to commit
and it's like oh well where did you
learn that commitment's unsafe oh maybe
you learned that relationships don't
work maybe you learned that if you do
commit you'll be left you'll be hurt you
don't want to open yourself okay
interesting well we could tap into that
so you have this physical platform with
you know the body and alignment and
method for that so then how do you use
that you're talking about all these
other sort of those are sort of looking
at it in a systemic way so what is your
role then beyond just body awareness
great question uh what my role would be
where I place my hat because I don't I
don't have enough expertise or depth in
the other topics
is the physical aspect and so if the way
that you feel will manifest itself in
your in your tissues you know like the
issues are in the tissues oh yeah mass
and Kip all the way right exactly so the
issues are in the tissues so I'll just
be physical and work on the tissues and
work on finding ease in Grace and
balance and removing the dis-ease from
the body from the lens of movement which
you can do and then if you're able to
actually create change in the body it
will start to spill into other aspects
of a person's life if you've been
walking around the world this is me
um growing up very insecure kind of like
broken home type type scenario
um really like great parents lovely I'm
I find myself being defensive around my
parents I think it's very common or not
with people in general you know love me
the best they could had their own issues
and really pretty decent home for a
while dad ended up getting into drugs
went to jail a lot of kind of stuff you
know percolating there now Dad's doing
really well he's now like starting to
face his own issues around intimacy and
things of the start we're having
conversations about it yeah it's it's
very nice but my response to that
physical home feels unsafe I will
compensate by making by building my
biological home my body up as fast as I
possibly can I'm going to get all the
muscle and fitness magazines and all the
Bro magazines and eat all the
supplements and be you know feeding
myself every two hours and protein
smoothies and creatine and like all the
different stuff lots of chicken lots of
farts lots of just like like you know
disease in my in my intestines uh but I
got very big very fast that led to
chronic pain that led to Joint
dislocations that led to becoming a
shittier athlete I played ice hockey for
a while as I got more interesting to
look at my skills on the ice like
digressed it was like every six months
I'm like wow I'm a worse hockey player
but everyone thinks you know I'm like at
the peak of my athleticism because I'm
I'm really big now
and so it literally it was like a I was
like an inverted pyramid in a way like I
was it was they didn't have like a
foundation and I think the foundation is
you know the way that you feel you know
and the way that I built my body was on
top of this Foundation of feeling
insecure feeling unsafe feeling like the
shoe is going to drop feeling like we're
not sure if we're gonna pay rent or the
mortgage not sure if dad's gonna come
home not sure if we're gonna have a
house so I'm gonna I'm gonna go whoa
okay let's let's build it up let's puff
the chest out and let's kind of strut
through the world to let the world know
that I'm safe I don't need help I'm okay
and then 20 years later you start
messing up your relationships and or
messing up your whatever something
that's it needs to be you need to have
something that's deep
in order to start to create change I I
believe
typically is relationships I think like
love like for a man it's like like the
tenderness and the sweetness of like a
girl a woman it's like oh there's
something really powerful about that
uh it it does something and
so for me that was kind of kind of my
thing to be like oh man I didn't realize
I learned when I was young that
relationships don't last
um and you know my parents got divorced
my dad went to jail
uh you know so and and growing up my dad
was I think
kind of like an alcoholic or like had
like issues with drinking
um so I I gather that now as being like
as a as a little boy I would almost have
to receive his avoidance and numbing
strategies as I'm not enough
right you know or it's not really safe
to actually feel
um like attuned and connected to you
because you're not actually a tune and
connected to yourself yeah so me as this
really like vulnerable imprintable
spongy being
that needs to depend on you to keep me
safe I'm gonna then reflect that back on
myself
and now it becomes my issues because I
need you to keep me safe as an infant so
whatever's happening with you
[Music]
it's I'm gonna I'm gonna take that
and just assume that you must kind of
have your stuff together and then you
know as a as a 30 you know 40 50
whatever year old a person that that
comes to a point where they start to con
you know reconcile some of that realize
like oh my parents are just yeah kids
they were just kids and they had their
own parents you know and they were all
of these things and you know I think it
starts to open up and then having I
think having the vulner having the
opportunity to have vulnerable
conversations with one's parents is also
um I found that to be really really
supportive as well even if I think
they've passed I think there's there's
ways I think you can maybe write letters
to them or you know have your own kind
of like more spiritual connection to the
parents but I think that connection to
the parents is very valuable your
childhood is a certain way that produces
a certain kind of pattern and then that
pattern plays out over and over and over
again and so until we see it and that's
the way it happens in my world you need
to confront it right so what was that so
was that a more recent realization for
you that
um okay yeah like last two months wow oh
wow that's very recent
it's crazy it's so cool
what's interesting is that I mean in
preparing for the interview I I heard
you saying what your goal for 2022 was
and some older interview I listened to
and your goal was to to not Chase
because once you achieve sort of like a
person it becomes unattractive anymore
and like yeah stop with this Dynamic of
chasing so the fact that here we are in
2023 just like and then a couple of
months ago like it to me you said the
pattern a year ago over a year ago
that's what I heard was like oh I'm not
gonna
yeah yeah it's been there for a long
time yeah interesting and so but now now
I'm actually in a like broke down
uh seeking help place which is which is
a better
disposition
because then you could actually you
could actually create change if you just
think your way through things we're like
I'll meditate I'll meditate more I'll
like go eat some more mushrooms or
something
um I'll work out harder I'll do it yeah
I think I think really for me I really
needed therapy I really needed a purse I
need to like my sober mind to uh you
know take account throughout the week
and say like okay like what are these
like what are the where are my
limitations like where where am I I'm
not able to push the ball forward on my
own uh and that's like not an easy thing
to admit as a guy I I think for a lot
again or for me at least yeah I want to
talk about two directions when I don't
want to forget but I want to talk about
the role of you know you said a sober
mind which I I get what you mean from a
kind of more macro perspective but also
like a truly sober mind versus achieving
it through mushrooms or Ayahuasca or
iboga or whatever kind of modality you
wanna whatever kind of medicine you
think might give you the answer
um you know that's One Direction
um well let's just start there let's
just start there like you say a sober
mind
was a different direction did you go a
different direction to try and sort of
reconcile certain things or uh you know
did you get did you flounder around in
that space for a while or was it a
revelation error like did you see did
you see a lot of Truth yeah I mean I've
done several
Ayahuasca ceremonies and psilocybin and
um you know things of the sort
um and I've I've I've garnered value
from all of them I would say
and I think there is something really
special and meaningful about the same
kind of thing of like learning to fish
you know so in a way psychedelics they
can teach you to fish and they can open
Windows to things that like oh I just
didn't know that was there and now I see
it so now I need to go into my sober
reality and start to create the
structure around that Sensation that I
felt but I think if you just get the
Epiphany and then you go back to who you
were
Nothing's Gonna Change like it it really
was nothing more than like an expensive
trip to Costa Rica you know so so I
think it it you need to have the
integration and you need to have the
restructuring and it it takes work and I
think the work comes not being super
high on something I think the work comes
in this like sober world and sober's you
know kind of a weird word I mean sober
you know in like the a yeah I know you
didn't but I also was curious about
plant medicine anyway yeah I don't have
strong opinions about about all of all
of the like AAA and all I've been to AAA
before for love addiction
um and for alcohol but not because I
drank alcohol I was just interested in
the meetings
um and there's something really
beautiful about AAA like being being
around a group of people that are
they're it's it's very
um religious in a way it's very like
Christian
um which I think there's value in that
philosophy as well uh and a big part of
that is really being like humbled to
your knees like that's kind of the vibe
of AA like I was on my feet I was
messing it up
I'm now on my knees like I'm prostrating
myself
like I can't do it alone
there's something really beautiful about
that and being around a bunch of people
ranging from you know successful
celebrity you know whatever Superstar
people to people that are you know a
meth addict in the street all being in
that place where like
I can't do this alone like I need help
vulnerability is the vulnerability part
it's not it's the other part of my
question had to do with it yeah I mean
it's it's I think it before you start to
lean into those aspects of yourself
I think it's it's uh I don't know it's
it's scary it's just shameful I think is
a big thing for me it just feels
shameful to not be strong enough to not
be uh able to be like the provider and
the supporter and the teacher and the
Healer to be like no like I need help
it's not it doesn't sound sexy to say
but and then the reality is I think
actually it is it is quite attractive if
you're stuck in that then it becomes
less attractive but having access to
that is it's like a part of being a a
whole human being which the meaning of
Health uh is an Old English word that
means whole
so Health whole if and that's where I
would come from the perspective of the
physical stuff the things that I share
on the internet are mostly like exercise
based and training and mobility and you
know nervous system regulation using
like breathing practices and stuff like
that
but behind all of that I think that
these are the things that I think are
more interesting to like
talk about and you know reflect on and
think about and integrate in your own
cell yeah yeah how do we become whole
business exclusively physical modalities
is a process of becoming whole when I
think of holy or even Enlightenment in
it just like I think of light filling in
the shadows and the the where where we
split or where refraction off in our
childhood in many many ways to cope and
survive like it's about how do we
reconcile that that that aspect that
we've
closed off shut down put in the dark
don't want to see
um you know how do we how do we light
bring light to the whole the whole
vessel the whole being the whole the
whole
um Consciousness the whole reality of
you that's the definition of Health yeah
and there's and and there are
for most people
there are
shadowy scary nooks and crannies within
ourselves yeah
just being open to that as a concept you
don't even necessarily need to buy it
completely and be like okay like yep
that's it but just be just kind of like
set that on the Shelf I'm like okay
there's are there any parts within
myself that I'm I'm not even willing to
look at and that's one and at some point
in a person's life this is comes from my
interview with Gabor as well uh one of
the things he shared was there's like
four pillars of a healthy child and one
of them is that a child needs to feel
safe to express every emotion
so if you grow up and at some point you
learn from your caretakers that it's not
okay to be angry or it's not okay to be
you know sad or it's not okay to be
anything one of the most damaging things
you could do to a child I believe and
that's you know what what Gabor shared
is is instilling that belief that okay
there's some ways of being that are are
okay
and then there's some other ways of
being that that are not okay these are
bad so now I will instead of feeling my
anger or My Rage which is a completely
healthy uh disposition like you have
anger circuits in the brain that's like
they're there
and so you're like well we will shut
that part down because this household
doesn't accept that then it's like okay
but now it's I think it's comparable to
like putting a piece of steak under your
rug and be like cool like we don't see
it you know it's it's just we'll just
we'll just put that right underneath
there
and it's fine for a while because I
don't see it anymore what's the stake
like in a month what's the steak like in
a year what's it stake like in 20 years
you know what's the what does that start
to do to the rug the juices start
seeping through the rug maybe it starts
to grow a little mold now you have a
whole life there's a whole ecosystem
growing around this initial piece that
you weren't willing to look at the
longer you go without addressing it
hiring a carpet cleaner you know maybe
you need to get a whole new rug you know
you need to like do deep work on
cleansing this rug and processing this
rug
it will just fester and go deeper and
deeper into all the annals of your life
yeah it's totally Jordan Peterson slay
the dragon when it's small before it
becomes a monster you know a lot of what
we're talking about therapy in
particular is relying on you being
vulnerable like
it's probably still not even easy to be
vulnerable with a therapist at times for
people because they just think well I
don't need to say that but or I don't
want to cry but men are being called and
asked more and more to access this
vulnerability within them to be able to
connect with themselves on a deeper
level so that they can connect with the
feminine and this is a really fine line
between you know connecting and not
being able to hold the relationship in a
masculine way there's so much talk these
days about toxic masculinity and like
let's not forget there's there's toxic
femininity and uh but but the masculine
and this vulnerability and how you
reconcile that and if you feel like you
understand it or are in a good place
with it I think yeah it's just a balance
I I think like that I think culture
presently is being instructed more
towards like toxic femininity you'd say
which you don't hear that toss around
too much because it's more like the
patriarch is bad masculinity had you
know it don't be too don't be too much
masculine within that you will probably
get a an imbalance in the other
direction and I think that you can go
into like maybe perhaps toxic femininity
where a person is I think you can be too
much just listening and too much just
nurturing and too much just soft and too
much just
like you also need to like have a having
like that's the father like it's like no
buck up we need to get this done let's
go it's like oh wow that was that was
kind of stern that was like directive
you know it's and so if we're just in
that
if we're too too soft like David guys
like stay hard like you don't want to
just stay hard but you'd also don't want
to just stay soft
there's there's a middle point you know
so it's like it's like bread you know
there's breads like too hard like stay
hard it's like no it's too hard you
burnt the bread there's like too soft
it's like well it's not ready no right
outside the world's dangerous
so what do you do how do you deal with
it
I think you you engage I think you have
mentors and peers and people that you
look up to and respect
um I think you uh I think I'm in process
with this personally I don't think that
I'm like a guide in this personally I
feel like I'm like I'm very much in
process
um but I think masculine things would be
uh creating calendars and schedules and
things to stay on time stay on task be
directive if I say a thing I will do a
thing like keep your word
um you know you could read The Four
Agreements you know uh Don Miguel Ruiz
you know like one of the things just
like like stay honest keep your word I
think that's one of them in there don't
take things personally you know like let
it let it scuff off like like you know
it's just like water on a rain jacket
like okay like yes but here we are let's
let's keep moving
um I think having you can adjust your
masculine your masculinity or the way
that you show up
as a masculine person or that aspect of
yourself through augmenting the way that
you move uh an example of that would be
maybe like if you're staring your phone
all day long and you're hunched over in
a chair and your body's kind of like
dilapidated and collapsed and you're not
getting enough sunlight and you're
eating a bunch of food that's causing
you to have blood sugar issues and you
know all sorts of problems you're not
ready to to be of service like you're
not you're not ready to show up and like
be the leader
like you're at a deficit
that's not very masculine
you know so masculine is cool I've done
my preparation I've organized my notes
I've got my fuel in I've got extra water
let's go
I was like whoa that's that's pretty
cool you know and then the the feminine
aspect would be practicing meditation
practicing deep listening with friends
or a partner
practicing art practicing dance like
fluidity spending time in nature
actually like opening yourself up to how
does nature move you how does nature
make you feel how does the sun on your
skin make you feel how does the taste of
the grapes that you're eating or you
know whatever whatever sensual
experience that you're having opening
yourself up to that
oscillating between that that's not a
biological male female
thing that's a human thing totally yeah
and and so both of those both of those
are are valuable it just so happens
generally
biological females typically are have a
stronger disposition
towards more feminine stuff and Men
typically have a strong disposition
towards more masculine stuff men are
good at defense yeah men are good at
protecting men are good at staying hard
women are really good at
um you know nurturing caretaking air
taking and yeah like connecting with a
child and like like a home and building
like a warm Nest it's so beautiful yeah
and we're living in a world where that's
all getting a little like shaken up
so do you think that
it's when you're properly in your
masculine that you feel comfortable to
be vulnerable and get into the feminine
or is this just a separate practice of
or maybe you could explain perhaps where
you feel the most vulnerable like what
makes you feel like you can be
vulnerable what are those environments
I think a person that feels insecure
will end up compensating and it will
show up as quote unquote toxic anything
sure so that's the that's the person
that you know they've got a barbed wire
tattoo around their steroided tricep
bicep situation and they've got you know
a Corvette with flames going out the out
the back and they're [__] doing
donuts
you know like the person where you see
it like it's like all attention goes to
that person in the street really loud
music whatever it's like I immediately
think they have a small penis
immediately small penis or they just
don't feel seen you know and it's and
it's it it's him to me and that could be
my own projection whatever but to me
it's I'm like oh okay like I see I see
that as like okay that person wants to
be seen
you know and so for that they feel like
maybe they're not worthy of being seen
so then they're going to compensate and
go into however each person has their
own flavor of compensation but the toxic
masculinity masculinity one I think will
probably be like I don't feel mad enough
uh I don't feel like a uh supportive
partner or mate on a team or in a
community I don't feel Dependable I I
don't I don't feel like I trust myself I
don't have self-trust I don't have
self-love
yeah so I'm gonna I'm gonna compensate
and show you why I am good enough
and then you can come to a point where
you start to work through that and then
once that starts to get worked through
either through uh re capitulating your
trauma which is what a person does that
gets that's like uh the Peter Levine
Awakening the tiger within uh type uh
perspective of all like the somatic
experiencing and such among other trauma
based modalities and therapies and
perspectives but essentially we will
start we will resurface our our trauma
until we heal it
and so every time you have you get into
a new relationship and well we're doing
the same thing oh here we are every time
you there's a story he actually has in
that in that book
where there's a a man that was in I
believe it was the it was Vietnam or
some I don't remember the exact War but
on a date it was like July 7th or
something he lost one of his close
friends in in war and he would show up
at a Quickie Mart
every year on this date and he would
pseudo-rob the Quickie Mart with a with
like a fake gun underneath his shirt it
was like his hand old you know senile
you know like not really totally with it
with a guy deeply traumatized
and he would act out this situation cops
would come guns drawn he's
recapitulating or recreating this trauma
because it's it's in him
and so he's he's finding ways for it to
come up to the surface because at a
subconscious level the the body mind
Spirit wants to heal it's a healing
system
you get a scar you cut yourself the body
just heals that's what it does
if you have a scar
and you are irritating it all the time
it's not going to heal
the body wants to heal it just needs you
need to remove the barriers to allow it
to heal yeah you know and that's like
there's a roomy quote I think he says uh
your task isn't to love your task is to
remove the barriers restricting you from
love if you were to sort of break it
down for people for a couple of really
beneficial physical
um activities and then a couple of
really beneficial mental emotional
activities how would you guide people to
the next level of their awareness of
themselves I think just you could just
say the physical and that would be like
tie in with the mental emotional
obviously like I said like I think
getting therapy is a good idea if you
have a good therapist I think just
seeing someone just talking about your
problems like it could be really good
but I think it really comes like vetting
out a therapist something that I found
really helpful actually was I talked to
someone that I know and trust who is I
I'm very grateful that I have access to
people like this who's like a
world-renowned and Coach therapist type
person so he has access to all of these
things but I seeked out that person
who I'm very grateful is just a friend
so I just texted him but I seeked him
out and I said here's my thing who do
you recommend and he's like ah
this this this is it like this person so
to me that was a really cool thing
compared to uh just looking up in like
the you know Googling for therapist near
me or something like that I don't know
if that's the best thing or going
through like your insurance or something
I don't I don't know you know EMDR is a
is a physical practice so if you're
taking a walk the way that EMDR was
discovered from my understanding was the
the founder she discovered it from
taking a walk and noticing the effect of
scanning The Horizon and as you're
scanning The Horizon you're going back
and forth you're looking and you're
walking and you're moving that's sending
the signal to your deep autonomic State
your your deep physiology that oh you're
moving towards progress
compared to I'm being attacked you know
and I feel Frozen you know there's a
there's fight flight and then there's
freeze like that's another aspect of
that cycle if if a person has the
opportunity to actually like move their
body and look up look up into the clouds
scan the Horizon back and forth like
mobilize yourself that's sending a deep
signal that you're moving towards
progress
so it's it is an emotional experience
like that's why a lot of the best ideas
come from a person taking a walk that's
why Steve Jobs you know invested
millions of dollars on having a walking
path outside of their facility so that
his employees could go be creative and
take a walk and get sunlight and get
outside that would be one thing I would
say just like get outside
you know most of the modern diseases uh
there you could refer to them as as
diseases of mismatch and what that means
is is just our physiology is mismatched
to this modern environment that we
created so we created this really
convenient environment but we neglected
the fact that a lot of that
inconvenience is actually what turns us
at a cellular level so now we take that
off of the table and now we Outsource
all of that healing movement to
technology and we just get kind of like
stuck up in claustrophobic and
dehydrated in our own cells
you need to move you need to express in
order to be healthy it's just the way
that it is yeah yeah so so easy ways to
do that I would say would would be and
this is like I wrote a whole book about
this essentially is it how to integrate
Fitness into who you are as a person as
opposed to it being like this
compartmentalized thing that you do
three days a week
um you know your whole day is Fitness
and so an example of that be like take
walking meetings
um you're getting natural sunlight you
know full spectrum sunlight as opposed
to sunlight through a window which
you're blocking out a certain spectrum
of the light uh
so that's a big deal as well so you need
to get out of just because you have a
window in your house it's better than
not having a window but you need full
spectrum sunlight it's like eating a
supplemented form of food it's just you
just need food like your body runs on
sun yeah so so uh you know sunlight like
incorporating that into your
quote-unquote Fitness walking is a
really beautiful way to help with
consolidation of memories so if you're
working on like a hard problem of some
sort or just work in general you're
studying for a test or something uh
maybe study hard for some duration of
time that feels good for you and then
intense to say cool instead of taking a
break from this and checking my
notifications on my phone and like kind
of dilapidating myself over into this
position and staring into my phone I'm
going to intentionally walk outside move
my body integrate the hemispheres of my
brain slash the rest of my body and
reflect for a moment and like process
like that's that's walking's one of the
greatest things you can do for yourself
and it's not it's not sexy and that's
how you know it's good most of the sexy
stuff are not that long of levers for
your health
you know it's the long levers are yeah
do you know it's pretty simple
I mean CrossFit is a perfect example of
that that's not a very long lover man
that that runs its course before you end
up being beat up the long lever aspect
of CrossFit is community and that's the
the longest that is the longest lever I
would say sunlight I would say is
probably the First Sunlight nutrition
and then Community I would say like the
base fundamentals like you need to eat
and you need sunlight next is community
period there's nothing it's not money
it's not it's like you need Community
meaning makes money you don't make money
without Community you don't make money
alone I mean I think I don't remember if
you've talked to Zach Bush or not but
the first time I interviewed him back in
um you know he started studied cancer
cells and what created what created
cancer and it was a lack of cell
communication which is essentially I
believe that this universe is fractal so
like we are an aspect of that and so
when we fall out of community when we
fall out of cell communication then
um bad things happen yeah yeah yeah or
or the right thing it's signals if if we
don't do the thing signals happen the
best definition for pain that I I really
value is is pain is a request for change
so Pain's just your body's way of saying
I'm not going to tell you exactly what
it is if you listen enough it's like a
relationship like your relationship to
your body is a relationship oh my God so
yeah it's telling you things and like
you think it's not actually telling you
things it is if you listen to your
intuition if you actually try and take a
second and pause and just trust it even
though it doesn't always tell you what
you want to hear there's actually
information within the signal of pain
re-relating your relationship to pain
as just a conversation and it's just a
request for Change and it's just
communication and it's not bad you're
not wrong you're not it's not like it
it's not something to be
um destroyed or attacked I'm gonna
attack the pain it's like there's ways
to actually come into relationship with
it and like list like listen even more
and
within that I think it's it's if if you
do allow yourself the spaciousness uh to
listen and typically it involves like
hiring help I think is really helpful if
you have the resources to do so
um or maybe read books you know YouTube
videos things of the sort you know to
get to get to the bottom of the thing
but I don't think there's a such thing
as pain expressed in the body that's
just because the body is malicious and
just because life is hard I think it's
it's I think it's it's all
miscommunication and the body is trying
to convey a message and the way that it
speaks isn't in you know English or
Spanish or whatever the way that it
speaks is in sensation yeah and the way
to tap into it is through tapping into
your your your sensation which comes
into very I think feminine approach
that's the feminine yeah I need to
listen deep feminine what is the
information telling me and you know I
think the the word that just came to
mind which is obviously such such a word
for you is when you're out of alignment
um the body will give you information
yeah whether it's emotional alignment
mental alignment physical alignment your
body's going to give you information
when you're out of alignment yeah yeah
it'll feel like chaos it's the same
thing if if you have
a railroad track and there's a train
going down it and the track is in
misalignment it's going to create noise
and Sparks and in The Human Experience
that would maybe look like anxiety or
fill the blank thing but anxiety to me
looks like Sparks and noise and it's
like that's the that's the feeling of it
yeah you know and so and so oftentimes
within like the spiritual Community
um I I experience uh sometimes like a
lack of stability a lack of uh like
ground Earth
and and so within that I think sometimes
it's like what the body needs in that
situation is maybe some bone broth you
know or maybe some deadlifts or maybe
some bench press or maybe like you need
iron you need to like feel resistance
and feedback and you need to organize
and recruit yourself and you need to
push
and you need to go you need to think you
can't do it and you need to keep going
through that's like whoa that oh oh
masculine now okay I understand I know
yeah yeah I mean and then you can go too
far with that where now you're not
listening you grind too hard that's kind
of the the issue with much of the
CrossFit World it makes sense that
there's probably reasons that you're
attracted to that in the first place
probably relates to like your
personality and old stuff for that it's
not bad it's not good we just seek out
the things that we're biased towards
based off of our history and the more
that we know about ourselves the more
that we can make more informed
decisions as the Observer and also you
know the like the the engager you don't
want to just observe you also want to be
in it because then you can get two you
can be two while I'm observing it's like
sometimes you gotta let go of
observation too if you want to dance you
don't want to be in the observation of
the dance you want to be in the dance
you're right because like one of the
last epiphanies in a psilocybin Journey
was that I was like this waveform and
that that's what it was at a baseline
reality and that that this this sort of
experience of being a human was just
waveforms intersecting and for it's
truly just for your experience so like
you can't just be observing of like oh
that's the dynamic you got to be able to
feel it and so I remember I was laying
there and I was like I was cold and then
I was like wait I'm not actually cold
this is just waves intersecting and then
it was like the energy was like told me
no no it's okay grab a blanket you're
just cold it's just the experience of
cold like there's it's not like you have
to deny its reality it's your reality in
this realm and so you know you just kind
of yeah have experiences allow yourself
to this is all it's the learning in my
opinion will never end and that will
always be on this journey of continuing
to you know peel away the layers of our
conditioning and of um where we have you
know fractioned off and and and hid
certain aspects of ourselves because
they didn't serve whatever was going on
in our life so I don't know let's finish
off with what um I'm curious what what's
the next thing you know I was kind of
inspired by you saying what your goal in
2022 was which sounds like what became a
reality you could sort of like arrived
at this um uh challenge or this
awareness of yourself so what's 20 23.
well we just launched a program which I
mean I can pitch but I won't like pitch
it too hard uh but that's been something
we've been focused on for the last year
and that's been really big for me around
organization this is saying like a lot
of the stuff that I've done on the
internet
my my background is like this like
somatic therapy type stuff but manual
therapy so Rolfing and like working with
organs visceral manipulation uh cranial
sacral therapy type stuff and then
physical movement you're training people
to move better
uh and then that shifted into starting
this podcast eight years ago and that
was around just having conversations
with people that I was really inspired
by and wanted to learn from uh and then
starting social media and it's been like
a lot of historically a lot of stuff of
like okay like just what I'm interested
in kind of a lot of stuff you hear from
this conversation and like what is my
role of like my service like where do I
serve the world best but that quality is
I think is very fulfilling
you know feeling like oh yeah like
especially for probably a lot of guys or
maybe just all people but that's
sensation like what is my role in the
tribe sure am I a carpenter am I you
know what like am I an electrician
and so that's been really supportive to
me too
really Define things writing the book
The align method was supported for that
as well uh but then doing the program
even more because it's broken down into
six six weeks each week is very specific
uh and the offerings within that it
gives me definition and containment of
like this is what it is it's not within
those six weeks then it's not really a
part of the brand so much presently and
so that's something I'm I'm really
excited about is creating more
um definition and structure within my
business
and then within like the heart stuff I
think really facing head-on intimacy
and commitment and not being a coward I
think is a big I feel like I'm a coward
I've historically been very much like a
coward of like being afraid you know and
and
uh I'm I'm good with that like I'm good
with with not being that you know and
opening myself up to to taking bullets
you know I'll be like okay like I'm I'm
gonna open myself up to this and I not
might get destroyed I will be destroyed
like it's going to happen and if you
open yourself up to love you're probably
you're going to have a much more
enriched fulfilled like open experience
with life and at some point Your Love
Will everything everything has its
sunrise and sunset and it will be
painful
and I think that I don't think I don't
think that's true you say that there
might be someone else it's like the
bodhisattva like has a total
Enlightenment you're like but they might
be out there so I think that it's
important that you understand that it
might be out there that you're not
turn the ash by being ready to take the
bullet by being ready to step in it
there's a absolutely a chance that that
won't happen yeah maybe but grief is
important
you know I don't think I don't think you
can grieve aspects of yourself that have
to die but it doesn't mean that a
person's going to do that to you no no I
don't mean to do that to me I mean
they're gonna die you know or they're
like like life you know any person that
you choose to open your heart to say
you're in a beautiful relationship with
someone for 30 years or whatever not
that that's the ideal maybe I don't know
there's probably a lot of models of
relating to to people that that could
work my preference is more towards that
um and but at some point one of you is
going to die oh okay I thought you meant
that it would be like some tragic
relationship
if you if you open yourself up there
will be grief oh so so so like just
accept like yeah yeah like I'm here for
it like I'm like I I know this is going
to be hard and that and that's what life
is that's me opening up to like actually
eating the avocado of life as opposed to
like I'm just I don't really try I don't
know if they might have salmonella I'll
just read about avocados and I'll become
I'll like pontificate you know and and
philosophize about avocados and their
depth and meaning because I know eat the
[__] avocado you know like take the
risk you know so I think I think that
would be something for me is is really
facing head-on like where am I still
afraid uh and where do I still have
subtle levels of maybe sabotage or maybe
manipulation of other people of myself
uh and just being very honest with those
parts and not seeing them as uh you know
bad or shameful but just seeing them and
saying oh this is this is what it is you
know like that wow like
damn I didn't I didn't I wasn't even
willing to look at that before so I I'd
like to keep on
uh learning I guess about about all of
those those parts that I haven't been
able to see I love hearing about
um a man's journey and and
the
the landscape of what it is to be a man
these days I don't think that the
culture makes it easy these days but
also makes it so much more open for so
many for it to look so many ways so
um and to be honest so
well done well done let's all get in
alignment I'm with that thank you I
appreciate that Danica I appreciate the
the
reflection of that that's that's I think
that sometimes that can be like
uh not always the easiest thing to like
receive
compliments sometimes for people it's
like easier to receive like oh how could
I do better but for to actually receive
someone that's like oh this is this is
like you're doing good thank you thank
you for this I appreciate it yeah of
course yeah thank you thanks everybody
for listening to the pretty intense
podcast today I hope you enjoyed it if
you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
Subscribe button